welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with The
Witcher now our worldwide on Netflix
it's time to break down everything that
you need to know about this show and
it's ending throughout this video we're
going to be going through the first
seasons overall plot the final few
scenes and our theories for what could
be happening down the line we'll also be
discussing the order of the show's
events and how the timeline for the
season works now obviously there's gonna
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the full season
yet and don't want to know what happens
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into our breakdown
of The Witcher Season 1
this is finally the moment you've
decided to actually care about someone
other than yourself Irish similar to the
source material and game adaptation The
Witcher follows Geralt of Rivia a
monster hunter for hire that deals with
the darker side of life living in a
world that mixes the balance between
mysticism and magic I'm just gonna be
giving a top-level view of the story as
it's very very dense and uh yeah it
could be sat here for hours just talking
about things due to the mythology and
inner workings of it this is one of the
most difficult breakdowns I've ever put
together so yeah just to keep it simple
we're going to be going over the main
events and how they interconnect there's
sort of three main pots that go
throughout the story line and all
intertwine making a brilliant narrative
though initially they seem disconnected
we see how events play into one another
and by the end they actually tie quite
well together
Ilyana Geralt is brought to a wizard
named straggle Bal a man hidden away
because of a target on his back who
attempts to hire him to assassinate a
mutant princess named rain-free that was
born under the Black Sun though he
rejects the job it's this path that
brings him into a world of war invasion
and he becomes thrust into the battle
between the forces of good and evil we
learn that there was a group of females
born into the Black Sun that came into
the world with mutations and powers that
could decimate the planet though the
majority of those possessing these
abilities were wiped out some still
remain as we learned throughout the
season the show really starts with a
bang of pasturing incredible at
large-scale battles across the screen
that have callbacks and nods to the
Battle of Hastings and many other
fantasy epics early on this feels like
an amazing replacement to fill the hole
left by Game of Thrones a Netflix spared
no expense when it came to production
values henry cavill - absolutely nails
Geralt and he really gets lost in the
character masterfully recapturing his
voice mannerisms and solitary persona in
a way that feels authentic there were
initially complaints about his luck but
within the first five minutes I think
you'll be completely lost in the
performance as he perfectly brings the
character to life elsewhere in the show
exists the subplot which centers around
princess Sarie
and her kingdom of sintra which is
upended when the forces of nilfgaard
over on it series mother died when she
was younger
and she's now looked after by her
grandmother kalantay who - passes away
in the opening of the season though she
does probably which I'll explain in just
a bit before her home is taken and all
of her friends are told to drink the
kool-aid
she's given the strict instructions to
find Gareth for protection and we
learned throughout the season that
series scimitar n3 possesses incredible
powers this is because as we discover
her mother had a mutation that may be
because she too was born under a black
Sun she was likely never wiped out
because of her bloodline and also
because Sentra distanced themselves from
the forces of straggle Bohr and the
Sorcerer's this has never explicitly
stated but I think it's heavily inferred
like a lot of the show is about drawing
your own conclusions and filling in the
gaps but we do know from the original
works that ciri was always destined to
become a witcher we learn in the show
that Geralt was in sintra during its
invasion but he was given a false child
to God and then imprisoned when he
discovered this the law of surprise was
broken and this is why Geralt was not
there for her when the Kingdom fell
though he does try to track it down now
the revelations of this season may leave
some confused
and the events of the show are difficult
to understand without fully laying out
the order that they happen in the show
plays very loosely with its chronology
putting certain scenes that actually set
things up in the first episode in the
midpoint of the season this makes the
timeline very difficult to wrap your
head around at points but basically the
majority of the Geralt story showcases
the events that led up to the birth of
ciri gerelds timeline mainly takes place
in the past
whereas series is in the present Geralt
catches up eventually but yeah this is
like a pulp fiction layout as far as
story goes series life and what led up
to it is what the show mainly revolves
around and as someone who had only
played The Witcher 3 I absolutely loved
seeing one of the game's main characters
in her infancy getting a fully fleshed
out backstory in the past Geralt el tren
free that if she kills Strega boar then
she will become a monster but accepting
this she in the protagonist go
head-to-head leading to him killing her
and ultimately being banished by
struggle ball who yet he's his
duplicitous as suspected yeah yeah
thumbs up if you guessed that Geralt
clearly ends up regretting this and
throughout the season he's haunted by
this big mistake
and the prophecy that rent free gives
him this puts him on a path with destiny
in which he'll eventually end up having
his life bound to ciri but along the way
he meets yennefer when we first come
across her she's a hunchback that's
completely unrecognizable from how I'm
sure most of you remember her from the
game or are there that sexy lads lads
lads straggler ball has his eyes set on
her and aside from Geralt she quickly
becomes one of the best characters in
the show though she's initially led to
believe that she's nothing she's
actually the perfect candidate for
ascension due to her emotion and
straggle Baal uses all of those at its
disposal to win her round this is
exemplified in scenes where she falls in
love with a mage after he shows her the
golden jellyfish that bring her aside
over the world that she's never seen we
then later see that a classmates are
transformed into eels and upon touching
the water they glisten the surface with
a sparkling electricity that slowly was
headed to becoming more trusting and
docile towards her captors yennefer was
born disfigured and crooked but through
a painful magic procedure she's
transformed though this comes at a very
heavy cost in order to be reborn she can
no longer bear children and her womb is
removed it cements how much the
sorcerers through manipulating her by
showing Beauty have changed how she
views the world which ultimately she
ends up regretting the timeline takes
place both in the past and present and
out of the arcs of the show it's
probably the most straightforward to
follow I think overall though the show
is really gonna get people invested in
all of the arcs as it's expertly
produced perfectly acted and yet there's
just a level of quality here that
elevates it above a lot of shows and the
fantasy genre it's too early to say if
this is better than Game of Thrones but
with that having a very lackluster final
season this definitely has the potential
to knock it off the top spot as it's a
really strong entry the game always
allowed choices for the players which is
also reflected in the show with Geralt
having to deal with the repercussions of
his actions it also presents several
episodes as what I would label as side
quests which while some may see as
filler are definitely in keeping with
the source material many things are
captured perfectly such as quests
changing their course of admission and
the creative team really thought about
what makes the game the way that it is
and how to translate this to a show
however this leaves some of Geralt
feeling a bit well sort of like filler
that while enjoyable add a little to the
overall plot but I will say they do have
a good variety to them this includes
hunting a quote-unquote devil reversing
a straggler curse and a princess
stopping a dragon and attending a
wedding you also run into elves who
after being stripped of their castles
and now live in caves hated and hunted
by humans who committed genocide on
their race we learned that yennefer is
real father was in Alphen this kind of
hints at how she developed such
abilities but because of human prejudice
the race is highly persecuted he'll ever
divulge 'sister the council who planned
to send her to know god but after a
transformation she wins the hearts of
many including the king of a gang yo yo
did you turn the playstation off get get
that sexy bug off get it back up this
vids for the lads the sorcerers are
using their mages to control each
kingdom strategically placing them in
order to rule the courts they
deliberately sterilize their mages so
that they can never have a family and
will always be tied to them but it does
backfire on those who resist with all
magic comes a cost but this one just
feels overly cruel and manipulative from
Jilla one of the sorceresses ends up
going to nilfgaard is she's sort of
cock-blocked by yennefer and this hints
at this invasion may be driven by her
though nilfgaard Sempra is said to be
behind it i know it's not something
again that's explicitly stated in the
show but we do learn that since she
joined the core they've had massive
advancements so she was likely
instrumental in the conquests she also
participates heavily in the final battle
so yeah this is just the conclusion that
it came to a lot of this is very much
filling in the blanks so yeah let me
know your thoughts in the comments if
you agree or not
yennefer detaches herself from the
sorceress after she fails to protect her
mother and son and sees the corruption
of the kingdom firsthand she leaves her
post and begins working as a mage
desperate to find a way to reverse her
inability to bear children she tries to
do whatever she can to rebuild her womb
it's during this out of path crosses
with Geralt and a to meet for the first
time Geralt who and wittingly unleashes
a Djinn
makes a wish in order to save her and
this eventually drives a wedge between
the two as it comes into question what
it really was the book actually never
says explicitly what was said in the
wish but the best
and theory that I've seen says that he
may have wished for the two to have a
baby together one day which would not
only have bound their fates together but
also reversed her predicament though she
can't currently have children it does
mean that eventually she may discover a
way to and yeah this was my favorite one
that I found
we don't ever find out what was said
though and it potentially creates
paranoia in yen who believes that he may
have wished for them to fall in love
yennefer who is desperate to have a
child becomes angered by this as she can
no longer trust her feelings and as
Geralt is sterile she is forever going
to be unable to have the thing that she
wants the most his lip service given to
a child at Geralt Balin himself - and
one that he lost which is of course
revealed to be ciri yennefer ends up
leaving though and being called to
defend against an elf garden patient in
this point of the show during series
timeline we see a stumble across a tribe
of women known as the druids that live
in broccoli and forest she's being
hunted tracked through the land by
someone known as the man with the winged
helmet shapeshifters men and those with
black hearts seek to find her and oh my
god I'm starting to talk like them one
disguises himself as mouse sack and
tries to tempt her into joining him on
an apparent quest to find Geralt but
through asking questions about their
shared history she discovers the truth
it's a real tense standoff and they
learn that they're being tracked by the
nilfgaardian forces ciri manages to get
away and we learn that the man with the
winged helmet is actually named cahier a
big character from the book that even
ends up joining Geralt at one point
throughout the story he does initially
come across as a villain and his arc
actually differs quite a bit from the
Netflix show in the book after serious
scape from the forces he was initially
jailed for a year
though this doesn't really play out here
eventually everything lines up for the
final episode with Geralt discovering
ciri after being helped by a man whose
life he saves and a mysterious character
this is actually a vision of a Senna
Geralt real mother
but Senna was a healer and sorceress and
similar to how they mean the show they
come face-to-face after gerelds badly
damaged she guides him towards Siri in
the to meet which ends the season and
leaves us wondering what could happen
next with ciri asking who yennefer is
now for the next season I actually think
it will center around Geralt training
ciri in the ways of the witch air and
pairing hair for what could be coming in
season 3 which I'll get into in just a
bit
the nilfgaard invasion will likely also
be a key point and I predict that Geralt
and Suri will join yin and Co and
fighting them once the girls training is
being completed in the books Geralt
actually ends up forming a romantic
relationship with fringe Ella
however he conquered yennefer oh it was
mine so he never dedicates himself fully
to her to be honest though I can't see
the show taking this route as foreign
Jilla is very much a bad guy in this and
yeah with a going head to head with you
and I think they'll position here more
is a villain rather than a love interest
there's also potential that the Wild
Hunt could be entering at some point as
they're mentioned in the first episode
and no I don't think this will be in
season 2 they will likely lay the
groundwork for next time
the Wild Hunt are desperate to track
down ciri and I think next time that
hair training will be completed and then
they'll come fair for season 3 overall
though the show is an incredible journey
and no I was initially quite worried
about the adaptation they completely
knock it out of the park
from the off this is a brilliant fantasy
journey that feels like the perfect
Christmas present from Netflix they
really spared no expense here and the
show is earnestly acted plotted and laid
out in a way that keeps the audience
guessing well so yeah The Witcher song
is a complete banger I actually got to
see the show early and I was singing
that for days because goddamn get get it
on Spotify right now it's banger if I
had to pick a fault with it I would say
that this show isn't really that
friendly for newcomers and I watched the
first five episodes with my wife and she
quickly got lost because a lot of it
requires either pre-existing knowledge
or just drawing your own conclusions if
it's piqued your interest though and you
still have questions and it's definitely
worth checking out the source material
The Witcher is brilliant and definitely
the one to watch this weekend and
Christmas break I absolutely loved it
and that's why it gets an 8 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on The Witcher and what you
want to see in season two comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then smash that like button make
sure you check out our full breakdown of
this weekend's other big release Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker which would
be linked at the end if you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of the air
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video but
she subscribed and leave your thoughts
on The Witcher in the comments section
below the one is gonna be chosen on the
15th of January and the subtle be
shipped out from then - ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to deafen issue
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]